Anna wants to
celebrate her birthday
by eating pizza
with her friends.
p boxes of pizza cost $40 total.
Each box of pizza costs $8.
Select all equations that
describe this situation.
So before I even
look at that, let
me at least try to construct
one in my own brain.
So p boxes of pizza cost $40,
each box of pizza cost $8.
So one way that
I could say, what
would be the total cost
of pizzas in terms of p?
Well it's going to be
the number of boxes
that I get times
the cost per box.
So it's going to be
p times 8, or 8p.
And the other way of
saying that, the total cost
of my box of my pizzas, 8p,
or I could say it's $40.
So 8p must be equal to $40.
And we have that captured right
here, in this first equation.
The number of pizza boxes is
p, you multiply that times 8,
because it's $8 per box.
That's my total cost
of boxes, which I also
know is going to be $40.
So these two things must
be equal to each other.
Now anything else
that I select really
has to be the same thing
as this first equation,
just manipulated a little bit.
So over here I have
40 divided by 8 is p.
So there's a couple of
ways to think about it.
If I take the total amount
that I spend on pizza, $40,
and I divide by the cost per
box, so if I divide by 8,
that should give me
the number of boxes.
And that's what this is saying.
Take my total cost,
divide by my cost per box,
and it should give me
the number of boxes.
Another way of
thinking about it is,
if you take both
sides of this equation
and divide both sides by
8, on the left-hand side
8p divided by 8 is p.
And on the right-hand
side, 40 divided by 8
is, well, 40 divided by 8.
It doesn't matter if we wrote
p equals 40 divided by 8 or 40
divided by 8 is equal to p.
They're just saying that both
of these quantities are equal.
So this is also another way
to describe the situation.
Now let's think about
this right over here.
8 divided by 40 is equal to p.
Well this is not consistent,
either with this statement,
or with some of the other
things that we checked.
Where on the left-hand side
we're taking the reciprocal,
and on the right-hand
side we aren't.
So these two things
cannot be equivalent.
Over here we have 40
divided by p is equal to 8.
So if I just said, hey
look, I spent $40 on pizza,
and I bought p boxes, how much
did each of those boxes cost?
I would say well, I would take
40 divided by p to figure out
how much each of
those boxes cost.
And they tell us to
that must be equal to 8,
that each box equals 8.
So this seems consistent
with what we just read.
And you can algebraically
manipulate any of these top two
to get to this one
right over here.
Right up here, if you
divide both sides by p,
on the left-hand
side you have 8p
divided by p, which would be 8.
And on the right-hand side
40 divided by p is just 40
divided by p.
So it's the same exact thing.
And the last one, you have
p is equal to 8 times 40.
Well we already know that p
is equal to 40 divided by 8.
So it's definitely not
going to be 8 times 40.
So that one does not apply.
So let's check our answer.
We got it right.
Let's do a couple more.
Molly and Tory like to
eat ice cream sandwiches.
Molly ate 5 ice cream
sandwiches and Tory
ate n ice cream
sandwiches in one week.
They ate a total of 12 ice
cream sandwiches together.
Select all of the
equations that accurately
describe the situation.
So Molly ate 5, Tory ate n.
So 5 plus n is the
total that they ate.
And they tell us that
that must be equal to 12,
that the total that
they ate together is 12.
So 5 plus n is 12.
So we immediately see
that one right over there.
Now anything else
that we check has
to be consistent with 5
plus n is equal to 12.
Or it has to be a way to
algebraically manipulate
from this to anything
else that is true.
So let's go one by one.
So is n minus 5 equal to 12?
So n minus 5 is going to be
the difference between what
Tory ate and Molly ate.
And that's not going to be 12.
Their sum is 12, so we're
not going to check that.
Here we have 12 is
equal to n minus 5,
which is an equivalent
statement to this top one, which
we already know is not true.
All they did was swap both
sides of these equalities.
So that's not true.
5 minus n is equal to 12.
Well that's just the difference
between Molly and Tory.
And that's definitely not
going to be equal to 12.
The sum of the two is
And then finally, well
we know this is right.
And then this right over
here, n plus 5 and 5--
We already know that 5
plus n is equal to 12.
Well it's a completely
equivalent statement
to say that 12 is
equal to n plus 5.
You're just swapping the
left- and right-hand sides
of the equality.
So let's check our answer.
Let's do one more.
Mr. Herman's class is selling
candy for a school fundraiser.
The class has a
goal of raising $500
by selling c boxes
of candy for $2 each.
Write an equation
that the students
could solve to figure out
how many boxes of candy
they need to sell.
So let's think
about in terms of c,
how much money they would raise.
So let's say they sell c boxes.
For each box, they get $2.
So the total amount they're
going to get is 2 times c,
or we can even just write
2c right over there.
So this is the total
amount that they're
going to raise in terms of c.
Now we know that the
goal is to raise $500.
So we want to figure out what c
does the total amount that they
raise, does that equal 500?
So this right here
is the equation
that the students could
solve to figure out
how many boxes of candy
they need to sell.
Let me check our answer.
And of course to
solve this, we're
essentially saying 2
times c is equal to 500.
So you might be able to
solve it in your head.
You might say 2
times what is 500?
And you would get 250.
Or if you wanted to solve it a
little bit more systematically,
you just divide both sides by 2.
2c divided by 2 is c.
500 divided by 2 is 250.
And you would get
c is equal to 250.